bentrovati bentrovati vorrei fare con
voi un piccolo viaggio di andata ma
soprattutto di ritorno attraverso alcune
mie esperienze lavorative con poche
anche anticipato nella presentazione per
trarre fuori alcune riflessioni che
magari spero vi siano utili
qualche anno fa lavorava per una società
che creava master post laurea quindi
master per laureati i corsi di
specializzazione all'interno di questa
funzione io mi occupavo di selezionare i
ragazzi che volevano accedere a questo
master di seguivo in tutto il loro
percorso e soprattutto ero a fianco a
loro in un momento estremamente delicato
momento in cui loro andavano approcciare
il mondo del lavoro cioè andavano a
sostenere i primi colloqui per
effettuare tirocini formativi
all'interno delle aziende è veramente il
tuo impatto col mondo del lavoro
in quella situazione che queste case in
questo caso qui io avevo una posizione
privilegiata che in genere non esiste in
un colloquio di lavoro c'era era un
terzo presenter un osservatore
sostanzialmente ho potuto osservare man
mano le dinamiche di questa di questo
incontro tra chi seleziona e chiesi chi
si candida per una posizione lavorativa
è quello di cui mi sono accorto che ci
sono dei passaggi molto veloci rispetto
a gli strumenti canonici il primo
strumento che si presenta in questo caso
è il curriculum vitae il curriculum
vitae è uno strumento che io trovo
estremamente restrittivo soprattutto
quando bisogna presentarsi per la prima
volta al mondo del lavoro è uno schema è
un foglio ci costringe a una sintesi
anche naturale è un po sostanzialmente
un elenco un elenco della spesa che
laurea e diploma che vuoto ed è tutto
molto uguale un po l'effetto è questo
qui della moltiplicazione contro c
contro v control c contro v anche per me
era molto difficile cercare di
intercettare le caratteristiche dei
candidati al master leggendo soltanto il
ricco di groove per cui durante il
colloquio la tendenza era quella di fare
un esame molto veloce di questo
momento che era molto impersonale
addirittura se voi ci ho fatto caso il
curriculum e molto impersonale anche
nella parte che ci dovrebbe
caratterizzare cioè quando si dice le
tue caratteristiche personali e lì c'è
un elenco anche lì molto standard per
cui si dice ho buone capacità di
lavorare in gruppo sono molto proattivo
e vorrei vedere che tutti presentasse di
un colloquio di lavoro per anziani
diceva odio lavorare con le persone non
nessuna voglia di lavorare
vuoi di una busta paga vogliono i nostri
beni che vuoi andare a casa per cui
capite bene che anche dalla parte che
dovrebbe minimamente caratterizzarci
questo non funziona l'effetto è un po
questo sostanzialmente di una
identificazione di una funzione ma non
di una persona quindi durante il
colloquio si parla si passava
rapidamente dal v al cs dico io cioè dal
curriculum vitae al chi sei per evitare
la proliferazione di situazioni sempre
uguali e perché c'era questo passaggio
perché fondamentalmente quando noi ci
troviamo a selezionare un collaboratore
un dipendente la domanda che ci poniamo
nella nostra testa è sempre questa me la
sono posta anche io quando mi è capitato
poi di dover selezionare le risorse cioè
è questa con che tipo di persona vorrò
trascorre più di otto ore al giorno per
circa cinque giorni a settimana per
tutta l'esperienza lavorativa che io
avrò con questa persona e soprattutto
questa grossa massa esperienziale come
influenza poi sulla mia vita privata
perché la nostra vita lavorativa in
qualche modo influenza la nostra vita
privata quindi vi rendete conto come
questo quesito è assolutamente strategy
nella selezione perché in fondo il
colloquio lavoro ancora prima che è un
rapporto di lavoro un rapporto tra due
persone e se ci riflettete bene il 94
per cento delle aziende italiane sono
micro e piccole imprese e le micro e
piccole imprese ancor prima che esse
delle organizzazioni economiche di
attrezzature di sistemi sono delle
organizzazioni di esseri umani sono
basate sulle relazioni delle persone
nelle pigro e piccole imprese che
caratterizza la nostra economia le
funzioni non sono così rigida non c'è un
non c'è un compartimento stagno tra una
funzione dell'altra
c'è un flusso lavorativo continuo
altrimenti la micro e piccola impresa
non sopravvive non funziona e per questo
che le caratteristiche si che iniziamo a
richiedere interno del colloquio si
distanziano sempre i tool da quelle che
erano le competenze quindi quello che tu
hai imparato nel tuo percorso scolastico
e si avvicinavano sempre di più alle
competenze personali cioè come l'intera
gira e tu col mio sistema economico come
interagire con me come interagire con i
tuoi colleghi quindi si iniziò a
distinguere tra le cosiddette hard skill
che le cosiddette soft skill una
distinzione è un po come dire
primordiale secondo me c'è se voi
leggete un po questa prima elencazione
che ho fatto delle soft skill vi
accorgete che alcune sono assolutamente
differenzianti a strategiche per il
mondo del lavoro
quindi la capacità di proattività la
flessibilità la creatività le capacità
di lavorare in gruppo davvero non quelle
millantate in un semplice è una sempre
voi un semplice quesito il curriculum la
motivazione cioè la capacità di essere
di mantenere la motivazione al lavoro
costantemente per tutto il pd lavoro le
capacità di networking le tecniche di
comunicazione perché a parità di
conoscenze la grossa differenza fra fa
come tu comunichi questa conoscenza come
tu metti in condivisione questa
conoscenza all'interno del sistema in
cui lavorerà e oggi voi qui sul palco
avete visto degli splendidi esempi di
persone che hanno delle competenze delle
arti il mosto importanti ma che
aggiungono a questo delle competenze
personali straordinarie e quindi rendono
fruibili per cui io mi sono appassionato
sostanzialmente al campo delle soft
skills ho abbandonato il lavoro
all'interno diciamo della del del
percorso classico formativo all
approcciato al mondo in cui si vanno a
sviluppare le competenze personali le
soft skills
le sottoscrive le vedo un po come le
sinapsi che collegano le cellule neurali
e spero di non dire delle sciocchezze di
fronte agli scienziati che abbiamo visto
oggi qui con questa loro capacità di
mettere in collegamento con la loro
eseguita e sottigliezza le parti
principali e quindi farlo e con la parte
di loro farle diventare rete farle
diventare sistema destinano la capacità
di essere adattabili di essere plastiche
di diventare ridondanti quindi
rinforzare il sistema ancora di più le
soft skill e immagina sempre un po con
un accordo del pianoforte cioè io le
compongo di volta in volta con un
dosaggio una combinazione diversa
secondo le esigenze quindi veramente e
quella parte delle nostre competenze che
ci rende fluidi nel mondo del lavoro e
se posso rinforzare ancora di più il
concetto delle soft skills le vedo come
la parte dentata di un meccanismo dove
noi abbiamo la parte centrale che l'ubs
film ma è la parte esterna quella che
mette in comunicazione quella che
trasmette il movimento quello che dà la
velocità quello che crea il flusso
all'interno del meccanismo tutto per cui
il mio lavoro è cambiato in sito a
guardare a tutto quello che la crescita
personale che è una materia più
tipicamente almeno fino a qualche anno
fa statunitense america dove il self
help l'auto aiuto cioè la capacità di
dire attenzione all'interno del mondo
del lavoro non è sufficiente
quello che so ma è necessario
qualcos'altro lì è molto chiaro questa
cosa poi pian piano è arrivata anche da
noi
e quali sono le forme attraverso le
quali noi abbiamo fatto cultura sulle
soft skill e sulla crescita personale
beh le forme si dividevano
sostanzialmente in due tipi l'aula
i corsi e poi i grandi eventi
io ho scelto la strada dei grandi eventi
un po come quello che state vivendo voi
qui oggi straordinariamente tra l'altro
qual è il dato interessante del grande
evento interessante le grande evento e
che noi potevamo con le città con cui
lavoravo selezionare quelle che sono
considerate le eccellenze nel mondo del
lavoro e il mondo dello sport nel mondo
dell'imprenditoria del mondo della
cultura
se tutte quelle persone che attraverso
un corretto mix di archi e soft skill
quindi dimostrando con la loro storia e
con loro studio e con loro
approfondimento il vantaggio di mixare
questi due ambiti avevano aggiunto delle
eccellenze è attraverso questi eventi
il nostro obiettivo è quello di fare
sensibilizzazione di fare emergere così
i cosiddetti il cosiddetto fabbisogno
latente di formazione sulla materia
delle soft skill l'aspetto ulteriore del
lavorare in questo ambiente è quello che
mi ha permesso di incontrare una serie
di persone così de considerate
eccellenti
all'interno di questa fascia d
eccellenza però mi sono accorto che c'è
un ristretto gruppo che io ho
individuato come persone straordinarie è
riconosciuto in loro queste
caratteristiche le persone straordinarie
quindi all'interno di un ambito già
eccellente hanno queste caratteristiche
vivono e operano in un flusso costante
cioè il momento eccellente non è un
momento è una costante in tutto quello
che fanno in tutti i loro atteggiamenti
in tutte le loro espressioni è il
momento del palco è un momento quindi
come dire c'è una continuità tra quello
che dicono sul palco e soprattutto c'è
una profonda coerenza tra quello che
dicono sul palco e quello che puoi farlo
fuori dall'appalto questo sembra secondo
una realtà è fondamentale le persone
straordinarie travalicano il campo di
specializzazione per cui come dire la
loro straordinaria capacità di mixare
hard stile soft skill e facilmente
replicabile in altri campi sono
appassionati di ascolto perché sono
persone che si pongono spesso in una
situazione nascosto e poi approfondiremo
questo aspetto si adattano continuamente
alle situazioni e questo lo possono fare
proprio grazie al giusto mix tra hard
skill e sofia questa capacità di tenere
lo sviluppo personale e coerente con lo
sviluppo professionale tre incontri in
particolar modo e mi hanno sollevato
questa riflessione erano stati
anticipati nella presentazione il primo
incontro è stato con il professor philip
kotler professor philip kotler è
consigliato il maggior esperto di
marketing al mondo forse dobbiamo
proprio a lui la codifica del marketing
conoscenza abbiamo organizzato un evento
con lui e c'erano circa 1.200 persone e
quello che ho notato del professor co 3
che in ogni momento di incontro in ogni
istante relazionale con ogni persona che
incontrava lui dedicava una fortissima
attenzione e focalizzazione che fosse il
manager di una multinazionale o fosse il
semplice appassionato di marketing
l'attenzione che persiste il professor
coter dedicava all'interlocutore era la
stessa chiedere un'attenzione
assolutamente focalizzata alla capacità
di costruire una sfera di attenzione in
torno all'interlocutore addirittura
questo signore di ormea 84 anni che va
in giro per il mondo ed e una di energia
divulgativa straordinaria porta con sé
nella giacca dei blocchetti e delle
penne e quando ha a che fare con
l'interlocutore mi fa questo gesto tira
fuori il blocchetto la penna prende
appunti si interessa vivamente a quello
che viene detto e questo crea nell'altro
una voglia di comunicare ulteriormente
quindi come di essi si genera un
moltiplicatore di comunicazione e di
scambio quindi ho trovato il fatto che
questo professore fosse straordinario
non tanto nel suo sapere ma in questo
atteggiamento di apprendimento continuo
in tutti gli incontri e poi restituzione
dal punto di vista scientifico
attraverso i libri attraverso i suoi
compagni
la seconda persona che mi ha fatto
riflettere su queste differenziazioni su
questa capacità è rudy bandiera ribadire
un divulgatore è una persona che
attraverso eventi pubblici attraverso
conferenze sta facendo un lavoro di
acculturamento su quello che è il vero
senso del web su quello che è la la
corretta visione nel mondo dei social ed
è una persona estremamente in panne
patica ed è strano
energetica cosa genera questa cosa non è
che ogni volta che lui definisce un
evento finisce l'intervento c'è una
massa di gente che ha verso di lui per
chiedergli consigli per proprio i
progetti per fargli proposte lui come il
progresso raccolte a questa
straordinaria capacità di focalizzazione
di momento relazionale il momento la
nazionale in più quello che ho imparato
a lui quello che vedo in lui e la
gestione del no perché è chiaro che in
un ambito di empatia dire sia delle
proposte e la cosa che ti fluidifica
meglio la cosa che favorisce meglio il
tuo lavoro
la cosa veramente difficile è dire dei
no e fare in modo che questi non siano
distruttivi o interruttivi del rapporto
ma occasione note garantiscano la
continuazione del rapporto quando lui
deve dire un no io ho notato che in lui
c'è proprio un momento di pausa capisce
che deve dire un no si interessa alla
proposta da una restituzione esatta di
quello che gli viene detto spiega le
logiche del suo non dover dire un no a
quella proposta quell'occasione a quella
opportunità e continua dicendo pur
tuttavia sono interessa tutto quello che
tu fai tienimi aggiornato vediamoci
sentiamoci per cui come dice questa
fluidità continua e per cui in lui ho
trovato questo esempio di gestione del
no all'interno del rapporto umano
il terzo personaggio che ho incontrato e
alessandro zanardi della persona dello
sportivo credo non vi debba raccontare
nulla evento con 1.600 persone lui un
carisma incredibile tutti cercavano di
far foto di avere un libro firmato con
lui veramente un flusso continuo anche
lui come le due persone precedenti
questa straordinaria capacità di
focalizzazione di persona in persona di
dare veramente valore ad ogni incontro
ho messo questa foto per alcuni motivi
perché mi ha suggerito alcune
osservazioni
a parte la mia espressione inebetita
dalla delle emozioni di incontrare
alessandro zanardi che vi assicuro
fisicamente a una energia carismatica
che da un certo impatto
proprio in queste foto ho notato alcuni
in particolare la prima è lui che mette
la mano sulla mia spalla perché mi dà
importanza capisce che per me con la
foto importante quel momento importanti
quindi valorizza quel momento
ma il secondo particolare che per lui
che lui per fare questo gesto abbandona
i suoi supporti abbandona e stampelle e
questo io che l'ho visto fare centinaia
di volte perché ogni volta che stringe
la mano abbandona le stampelle
ogni volta che firmo un libro abbandona
e fan pelle ogni volta che suona foto
abbandona le stampelle ho fatto questo
tipo di lettura lui fa una rinuncia
continua al suo equilibrio più di
garantire una qualità relazionale e uno
sbilanciamento continuo in favore della
relazione
bene quindi tutte queste persone mi
hanno stimolato a riflettere
sull'importanza dei momenti relazionali
in ambito business in ambito marketing
abbiamo sempre definito i rapporti prima
business to business poi business to
consumer poi kramer qualche anno fa ci
ha dato un input dicendo i rapporti
devono essere human to human secondo me
la il passo successivo è questo il
relation to election cioè la costruzione
della nostra rete comincia veramente di
momento relazionale il momento nazionale
perché la rete di relazione il luogo
dove noi viviamo è la traccia del nostro
viaggio all'interno deva dei nostri
studi sociali dei meccanismi economici
all'interno del quale noi andiamo ad
agire la relazione è il primario
elemento di resilienza e longevità un
tessuto sociale e tanto più resiliente
quanto è alta la qualità dei suoi
rapporti addirittura negli ultimi studi
sulla longevità che sta portando avanti
ad esempio il professor longo e
studiando le piccole comunità della
sardegna della calabria si è notato che
a prescindere
lo studio dell'alimentazione dell'acqua
del clima veramente veramente strategico
importante per la longevità e la qualità
delle relazioni quindi apprendimento
continuo restituzione costruire sempre
delle razioni di qualità nel sì nel no
una rinuncia all'equilibrio per andare
verso l'altro secondo me segnano
l'opportunità di una nuova era
relazionale che io ho sfruttato il
concetto di hera come acronimo per dare
tre momenti fondamentali quindi empatia
riconoscimento ascolto l'empatia è
quella capacità di entrare
contatto con con l'altro il
riconoscimento è non solo entrarci in
contatto ma identificare la sua scala
dei valori il suo messaggio è
riconoscere la sua scala di colui che il
suo messaggio
l'ascolto è l'arma strategica perché in
questo momento le persone straordinarie
quella nicchia di cui ricevevano una
straordinaria capacità d'ascolto la
capacità di ascolto e va allenata perché
è una di quelle soft skill veramente
deboli facilmente credibili specialmente
del mondo di oggi noi abbiamo un rumore
di sottofondo costante continuo dalle
relazioni dalla della tecnologia come
abbiamo visto in tutte queste giornate
la capacità discorso è continuamente
minacciata ma soprattutto la quasi
ascolto è quella capacità che gira le
vere la vera qualità nelle relazioni e
si è fatto casi in questo momento noi
parliamo sempre di emissione di messaggi
ci invitano a parlare più lingue ci
invitano a fare storytelling cimino a
raccontare ci invitano a raccontarci ma
nessuno ci insegna ad ascoltare e anche
nella nel linguaggio popolare si
individuano delle persone che sono degli
ottimi oratori difficilmente sente
parlare di ottimi ascoltatori è una
facoltà che nessuno prenda in
considerazione ma che in realtà fa
enorme differenza se ci pensate nei
momenti strani della nostra vita
noi siamo un po sballottati dai marosi
alla vita dobbiamo prendere decisioni
così viene consigliato cosa ci viene
detto che mi ha detto ascolta il tuo
cuore è lì tu ti rendi conto che è la
cosa più difficile perché devi far
tacere i pensieri fare sistema e
metterti in contatto ascoltare e se è
difficile ascoltare se stessi e c'è un
allenamento figuratevi quanto può essere
differenziante sviluppare la causa vera
di ascoltare gli altri
ad ognuno di noi raccontano delle storie
quando siamo piccoli le storie delle
favole a me raccontavano la storia di
mio nonno di un uomo che era tornato a
piedi dalla russia è lì per lì mi
sembrava
un'impresa a favolistica poi alle scuole
medie che hanno scoperto ulisse o
associato questa storia che mi veniva
raccontata da piccolo di quest'uomo che
era tornato dopo la seconda guerra
mondiale a piedi della russia fino a
foggia mi sembra un po il nostro ulisse
di casa in qualche maniera che va
affrontato battaglia va affrontato
mostri per tornare in un luogo
crescendo ho avuto l'opportunità di
documentarmi su questa epopea tragica
italiana su questa armata mandata a
sacrificarsi nella profondità della
russia e poi costretta a ritirarsi alla
meno peggio attraverso questi territori
assolutamente ostili temperature al di
sotto dei 27 gradi
attacchi continui da tutti e tutte le
forme ed esercito del russo diritto
arrivavano delle cavalleri e con delle
sciabole che scivolando facevano saltare
le teste ma non veniva a fare una goccia
di sangue per l'eccessivo freddo persone
che un certo punto si sentivano per dire
prendo una pausa rimane voli congelate
per sempre interrompendo il loro cammino
e mi sono chiesto mentre sinceramente
leggevo questo libro cosa spingesse
queste persone a fare passo dopo passo
che quale era la forza che gli dava di
andare avanti quale quali era il
pensiero che avevano perché in quegli
anni dove visto soltanto distruzione
intorno a te per cui non avesse trovato
più casa tua la strada all ufficio non
sapevi che a forma di stato avresti
trovato quindi vagali assolutamente nel
buio è l'esperienza di quest'anno uno di
questi anni mi ha portato a darmi una
risposta tu non torni in un luogo tu non
torni in una casa
tu non torni in una strada tu torni
nella tua rete di relazioni torni a
rimetterti la tua rete delle nazioni e
allora se è vero che noi non torniamo in
un luogo fisico
se è vero che la rete di relazioni che
sono i momenti e nazionali che fanno la
differenza nella nostra vita
permettetemi una chiusura un po strana
pronte dx è un evento internazionale
perché io attraverso questo evento
vorrei iniziare a smantellare
un motto che ho sempre trovato
antipatico e fare questa trasformazione
non sentirmi più dire in giro
fugge da foggia non per foggia ma non e
sfoggiare ma si torna a foggia non per
foggia ma per le relazione per i
foggiani
grazie
[Musica]